Okay.
So we've been talking about electrophilic
addition and the nuclear fillic aspect
of it.
And today we'll extend that to talk about
Psycholo audition and also there'll be
some practical applications with respect
to epoxides and ask the towels and how
they work. Okay, so first
about that problem, uh,
I gave you last time about drawing nice
curved arrows to show the Pinot call
rearrangement. So how does it start out?
What's the first thing that happens?
Wells. Do you have an idea
for acid ketalysis here?
What's the very first thing that happens?
Do early in the morning?
First funny. Sorry.
Probates. What? Okay.
So protonate the Oah and
then water can leave.
Why is it good for water to leave,
Chris?
Okay.
Uh, yeah. Oh, three
plus. He's good at losing things. How
about the other aspect I'm going to have,
I think it's leaving other
than the water charge. Yeah.
How about where the charge goes?
What's it going to be when the water
leaves? The water will reduce your trash.
Pardon me? That from a positive
charge. Neutral charging space.
Yeah, the water wheel. But we're caring.
We care about the organic thing
more than about the water.
We left a negative check. No, no.
The thing is a cad. I am,
if you lose neutral water,
the charge will stay.
Where will it be on the art?
Is that a good place for it to be?
A yes. Why?
Why is tertiary store share?
All right. Okay. So we get a nice tertiary
cat. Die. Now. Does anybody, what?
Did anybody think about the
next step here? Yeah, Kate.
Uh Huh.
I thought I'd shift good.
So the method could shift
over at rearrangement.
And now you have this cat I and now, okay,
you're going to tell me about this cat.
I, and we started already with a very
good cad ion, a tertiary cad ion.
Right? That's as good as
they get with, uh, with,
unless you have double bonds next door.
Okay. But what's the driving force?
Why should it go this direction?
What's good about being on the right?
Uh, uh, no, I don't think
you could say the CEO,
but it's true. It's true that
the CEO bond is a lower Lumo. Uh,
but to the extent that the oxygen, the
reason it's low is because of the oxygen.
Right? And that oxygen is
withdrawing charge from carbon,
withdrawing electrons from the carbon
tended to make the carbon positive anyhow.
So if the carbons already positive,
it's not such a great place
to put more positive charge.
So to the extent that that
sigma bond is important,
you'd think it would
go the other direction.
The oxygen would be electron
withdrawing and destabilize a cat. I am.
Can anybody see why it could be good
to have the oxygen next door?
It's certainly not that sigma bond.
What about the unshared pair?
Yeah. You know, actually
I would say the other way around
the electrons or something real.
Right.
And they get stabilized by mixing with
the low vacant orbital that's associated
with a positive charge. It's the
electrons that get lower in energy. Okay.
But you're absolutely right.
So you can draw a resonance structure
like that and that's why it's good to go
to the right. Okay. Now how do
you get from there to the product
Jack? Yeah, you just lose a proton.
Right? And you forgot the
product. So that's the niche,
the mechanism of the pinnacle
rearrangement. It's all
steps that you, uh, no, well,
but you have to think and
put them together. So that's
just an exercise in that.
Okay.
Now,
back to these simultaneous reactions
that are involved in addition to alkanes.
Simultaneous in the sense that
there's both a electro file,
which is what they're typically
called electrophilic additions,
but also a nuclear file that's
participating at the same time.
When we saw this last time with,
with Dai chlorocarbon,
which your neighbor came on edge on and
then rotated in order to make the two
new bonds to give a cycle of propane.
And we saw it in hydro bore ration
where the vacant orbital on the BIA tax,
but at the same time,
the high a homo B h, uh,
mixes with, with the,
uh, with the, uh, uh,
Pi Star orbital.
Okay.
So now we're going to go on to a different
kind of way of making a cyclo propane
with what's called the
Simmons Smith Reagent,
and then into an epoxidation add
in just an oxygen to a double bond.
To give a three membered oxirane
ring and then Ozal analysis,
which is a,
uh,
a more dramatic kind of cyclo audition
to give a ring and then we probably won't
get today to a catalytic hydrogenation
and to a polymerization and metathesis
wear metals are involved. So
we'll do those others. Uh, today,
first so called Simmons Smith,
uh,
our reagent or a car being annoyed.
We talked about CCL two
a car been last time.
That's a free species. It's pretty
reactive but it's, but it floats free.
It has an existence.
These are called carbon oil because
they don't really give a free car been,
but they give a product as if it were a
car being that is the ch two in a three
membered ring and the the
reagents as you can see,
our uh,
uh,
methylene iodide ch two I two and
a thing called zinc copper couple.
And I don't know where the name couple
came from except that they're two metals
there.
But it turned out that having a little
copper with the zinc made it work better.
So I don't know. Anyhow, zinc as
they is the operative group here.
But something the copper clearly
has something to do with it.
This was developed at dupont
central research in Wilmington,
Delaware where Howard Simmons
was the director of research,
first of worried about metals
and [inaudible] highlights.
So you have a metal and an Al Haylight.
Now metals tend to be over on
the left of the periodic table.
What does that mean about their electrons?
Are the highest valence electrons held
tightly or are they able to give up
electrons
compared to most things?
They have a high homo.
Yeah.
Things that are on the left
of the periodic table don't
have such a big nuclear
charge given the row they're in.
So they're relatively good at
giving up electrons. How about rx?
What makes it reactive?
A halide on our,
what's its characteristic reactivity?
Ayesha?
Yeah,
low Lumo Sigma Star.
So we have something that could give
electrons and something that can take it.
So it won't surprise you that this,
that you can get an electron transfer
from the metal and it's just uh, you know,
a metallic metal. It's not an ion in
solution, it's just a metal. Okay.
But at the surface of the metal and
electron could be transferred to Rx.
Now where does that electron go in the rx?
I show you got us onto this.
Yeah. What oracle does it go
into and what does star mean?
That
the bonding.
So what's going to happen when you
put an electron and get our x minus?
It's also a radical, it's got an odd
number of electrons. But what does,
what's the role of that last electron?
What does the star mean?
Anti-Bonding what happens?
You put electrodes in the anti-bonding.
Orbital. What does it do? Right?
Breaks the law.
The electric
brakes breaks the bond.
Okay,
so that the apair we'll go there and now
you've got x minus and the are radical,
but the are radical is generated
right next to them to the metal.
So you can get a transfer of making of
a bond between that radical
and an Adam in the metal. Okay?
So you get an owl keel,
metal bond, and x minus.
This is shown,
uh,
this is shown as if the
metal is divalent like zinc.
So it makes a bond to our and has a
positive charge and then it's associated
with the x minus. If it had been
a monovalent metal like lithium,
then it wouldn't have had the charge.
It would be our lithium. Right.
And there would be two lithium
Adams would've been involved.
Another one would be lithium
plus that goes with the x
minus. But at any rate, uh,
this is how you make, uh, uh, Al
Kio metal bonds in the first place.
Okay.
So the next three slides
suggest a plausible mechanism
for this formation of the
Cyclo probate. But as we'll
see, it's probably not correct,
but let's just take this as an
opportunity to practice, uh,
figuring out how mechanisms might work.
Okay.
So we could react zinc
with a methyl chloride,
right. And we get, uh,
we get this reaction that was shown
on the bottom of the previous slide,
a metal zinc bond and chloride.
And I've shown it covalent between
the chloride and the zinc. Right?
We showed plus minus last time.
Okay.
And this we're going to use as
a model for the actual reaction,
which had a ch two I two as the
starting material with zinc.
So it gave I z e n c h two eyes.
So we've simplified it here so we can
draw orbitals that are a little simpler.
Okay?
That's the Lumo of that model compound.
And mostly it's a four
s orbital on the zinc,
which is anti bonding to the things
on either side, right? Which,
which take away part of it. Okay. Cause
you have anti-bonding nodes there.
Of course.
So that's the Lumo and the homo
is mostly a p orbital on the zinc.
Okay? That's actually
the Lumo plus one. Okay.
Now if you bend the zinc,
you'll mix those two.
They'll hybridize. So if you bend
it, that's the four P on zinc.
If you bend it as it's approaching the
transition state where the zinc is going
to be approaching the CC double bond,
then you hybridize that central one and
you get an orbital. It looks like this.
And that's an sp hybrid sp
something or other on the zinc.
Okay. Now notice that,
that uh, that's the Lumo,
right?
So what's it well set up to
do with respect to the alkene?
What can it overlap with?
Amy Sigma is down in the middle
of where the of the carbons,
the pie right is sticking up where
you need it to overlap. Okay?
So that can overlap with the homeowner
and you're going to get a pair of
electrons that's bonding
between these two things,
between the zinc and the two
carbons. Okay. But this is again,
one of those cases.
So we have an electro file on
top of Lumo attacking an Alkane,
but we can also look at the homo on top.
Oh,
that's the electron shifting
into the bonding region.
So we can also look at the homo on top.
And what does that look well set up to do.
Matt, what do you say it
with respect to the alkene?
What orbital of the alkene
could that react with
the,
yes. What about the double bonds? Which
specific? Orbital. That's a double bond.
The Pi Star Five Star, right?
Which is the vacant orbital,
which is what you want this, the whole
model. The Lubo downstairs is the,
is what we want there. And you see
those are well set up to react.
So we could do electron donation in the
other direction. Top to bottom. Right?
So were you were taking electron pair
from top to bottom also previous slide,
bottom to top. So we're
forming two new bonds, right?
So we can draw curved arrows
like this and like that. Right?
And what we've done now is
form this product where zinc
is added at one side and
methyl at the other.
Okay.
Now if head we remember this, we just
drew. So the orbitals would look simpler.
If we had been using that thing that
had to Aja dins audit instead of one
chlorine,
then the product would have been,
this would've been the same
reaction. Okay. But that
would have been the product.
And now what makes this reactive?
Could you see where there
might be a low Lumo in this?
Any ideas?
Cassie Sigma star in
the carbon halogen bond,
right. That would be a low
Lumo. Okay. How about the homoe?
Where would it be an unusually high homo?
So carbon with a halogen is unusually low,
right? What's the analog that's
unusually high carbon with what
was a battle right is unusually high.
So the carbon zig bond would
be unusually high. Sigma,
zinc c and the Lumo is sigma star CCL.
I left one of the C's out. Okay,
so could you see what could happen?
Yeah,
what, what, what, what?
So you have a high homo
attacking a c x Bod.
Where have we seen that before?
What reaction has a high homo attack?
Sigma Star see x where x is a halogen?
Pardon me? Okay. Theories.
Hydro duration is such a case,
and I'd have to think about
whether this is an example.
I had an even simpler example in mind.
S and to write a backside
attack by the high homo.
So we can have the homo form
of attack, the carbon, right?
The iodide is the leaving group, right?
And that then would form the double bar,
the the three membered ring.
Okay.
So that's a very plausible mechanism.
It has two steps.
First you have the addition of zinc,
zinc,
haylight and the,
and the carbon group.
And then in a second step you do the,
the sn two type reaction to
s to form the second bond.
So the first reaction for them,
the bond on the right between the two
seats CHDS and the second reaction form
this one. Okay, but that
probably is not the way it goes.
It's probably not to transition states,
we just guessed that.
But there was a quantum
mechanical calculation of
what the transition state for
this should look like and they
found something different.
So although that mechanism is plausible,
it probably occurs in a
single step according to this
calculation with this bent
transition state.
Okay.
So this is the transition state where
everything is happening at once.
And let's look at what that is.
Okay.
First we could look at how the thing
moves through the transition state.
You see the carbon's going closer.
The IOD is going away from the
carbon and the zinc going away. Okay.
Let's see what happens.
Notice incidentally that the ch two
group is like this and is rocking in.
Where have you seen that before?
Yeah.
Where's the ch two group is so excitable
approaches sideways and then rocks in
seen that before. Ellen. Yeah,
a true,
a true carbines CCL two did exactly that
in order to get the orbitals to match
up. So let's look at the orbitals in the
transition state for this on the way to
making the cyclo propane and,
okay,
so this is at the transition
state geometry, right?
And here's the Lumo.
What is that?
That the Lumo of the zinc reagent.
Okay.
What would you call that? Orbital. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah. Sigma Star between
zinc in the eye then. Right,
so that's the Lumo and it mixes.
You can see it's well set up to mix
with the Pi Homo at the same time.
This is the homo minus two,
so it's very near the homo.
So very high energy or but what's that?
Well set up to overlap with Matt here,
our expert on this.
What about the Alkene as well?
Set up their Pi Star, right?
Blue on the right. Read on the left. Okay.
So we can do both of them at once and
make the two new bonds and break the
others. Okay. Now, here's the next
reaction we want to talk about,
which is an analogous reaction in the
sense of forming two bonds at once with a
reaction between an alkene
and a per carboxylic acid.
If we didn't have the red oxygen there,
if that hydrogen were directly
attached to the oxygen,
below that group would
be a carboxylic acid.
This is called a per asset per means.
Two oxygens linked together,
which is of course not a very stable bond.
Do you remember why it's not so
stable to have two oxygens in a row,
right? You have two pairs of electrons
that are repelling one another across the,
across the bond.
Okay,
so that's a medical hero per benzoic
acid is a commonly used reagent for this
and the product you see,
he gives the more stable carboxylic acid
and oxygen attached to the double bond.
Our question is what the mechanism is.
It's also interesting to wonder why you
use metta chloro per Roxy benzoic acid.
Why up? Why not para? Why is it
that just seems a weird choice.
It's interesting why it's chosen.
It's because it crystallizes very easily
and that the crystals of it are very
stable. So it can be stored for a very
long time without NDD composition,
even though essentially it's
rather unstable compound. Right?
So it's that practical application that
means that this particular one is the
one that's often chosen,
although others could be used as
well as there are groups on the,
on the per acid functionality.
Okay.
So you see that in this particular case,
which I took as an example
from the Jones book,
it was done in a at 25 degrees,
had benzene for five hours and gave
an 81% yield when our is and Hexcel.
So it's a pretty good reaction.
Okay.
So to look at what the
orbitals are involved,
let's just make that our group
instead of Metta Chloro, uh,
benzene, make it the, uh,
make it just a hydrogen.
So this is per oxy formic acid where the
extra oxygen is obviously here and that
hydrogen been here. It would've
been formic acid. And let's just,
uh,
distort that to the geometry
it has at the transition state.
So you see the oxygen oxygen
length increased a little
bit in the hydrogen bent
up a bit. Okay. Now we'll rotate it.
So to get the idea of how we're going
to look at it and rotate it back a bit.
Okay. And now we're going to
look at the orbitals that has,
so it has a bunch of occupied orbitals of
course, but the one we're particularly,
and it has a bunch of unoccupied orbitals
but we're particularly interested in
its Lumo.
Okay.
What's the Lumo going to be at Lisa?
What do you think?
There's several possibilities
that come up with anything.
Anybody else got an idea?
Carl Sigma Star.
Oh remember that's oxygen. Big
Negative. Big nuclear charge.
Okay.
Can you see any other thing that might
be a low Lubo Carl Pi Star of CEO is also
low. So in principle either of those
might be the reaction. So you learn,
you learn.
So that's the really the problem often
in choosing mechanisms that there's
several possibilities and you
have to consider them all.
And if they're, you know,
two possibilities and then at the
next step to more in two more,
just to be a pretty big number.
But at any rate,
those are the two that you
might consider at the beginning.
And once you know that,
once you've tried these several paths
than you can see which one's going to give
you the product that you know by
experiment is actually the product.
And it turns out to be the,
this one, the sigma star. Oh,
okay. Now, uh,
now how about the Lumo of this thing
or the department? That was the Lumo.
Here's the homo. Actually it's not
the homo, it's the homo minus three,
but,
but do you see what it's made of?
Yeah.
What's this big thing here?
That's The p orbital on oxygen,
right? The unshared pear.
And it's mixed with this up here,
which notices three p orbitals in a row.
Right?
So that's a p orbital on
this oxygen and that, uh,
the Pi electrons of the CEO Double Bond
mixing together in a bonding way here,
but anti-bonding here.
That's why if it had had been bought,
had this been read in that been blue,
then this would have been
a lower energy orbital.
So this is the anti-bonding combination
of those two and it happens to be home
minus three. Okay, so that's the, that's
the homo we're going to be interested in.
So that's mostly as we said,
the Pi on that oxygen,
the p orbital and also Pi Alcoholic.
Remember Al Lilly is three P orbitals
in a row all pointing in the same
direction.
So they overlap side decide.
Okay.
And there we've turned it a little further
just so you can see that it's those p
orbitals and now we're going to look
at it as it interacts with the carbon
carbon double bond.
So the first interaction is going to
be that that Lumo of the oxygen oxygen
bonds Sigma Star,
that's the electro file.
That's the Lumo and the high occupied
orbital is going to be our old favorite,
a Pi of the double.
Okay,
so that will do this. What does that
reaction reminds you of? A little bit.
When something comes in from one side
and a group believes with its electrons
from the other side,
sn two of course.
So it's the same kind of reaction.
Okay.
So that's an sn two attacking
oxygen, not carbon of course. Okay.
So that's going to form a new bond and
the leaving group notice is a fairly good
and I on Carbox alight,
right.
Better Than Ben r o minus.
Okay.
Now what makes this reactive?
What could happen next? Elisa?
Oh,
we it
positive charge on carbon. So that's going
to be a very low energy orbital there.
Okay.
And uh,
where it could be a Hobo
that would react with that.
Hi.
Occupied Orbital Leon.
Okay. It could be that that
wasn't what I expected you to say.
That's going to be what it is.
But what other possibilities Leon
[inaudible]
Leon,
what are what,
what other possibility is there in that
when you look at this picture for a high
homo,
we've got a negative charge up here.
This oxygen looks to me like it has
a higher homos and this one does.
What advantage does yours have
over the one that's up there?
Pardon? It's closer, right? So the,
the electro file is going to be what Elisa
said that the p orbital on the carbon
plus,
but the p orbital on the,
on the oxygen is going to
be the nucleophile and it
has the advantage of being
nearby. Okay? So that,
that means we can do this
and make a second bod.
Hey,
and of course the plus charge will
move when we share the electrons.
Now what do we have for a Lumo here?
If we're going to do another reaction,
it's something to do with
the positive charge. What,
what particular orbital would you point
to if we had to choose a particular
orbital? See the, the, the
charge is not an orbital.
The charge makes an orbital low,
makes the electrons in an
orbital low in energy nearby.
But what orbital will we look
at? Jack, you got to idea,
all right. Pardon me?
I couldn't get a pie.
Which pie?
A
Oh, a. A P orbital on
oxygen. Uh, there's not a,
that's not a v P orbitals on oxygen
are all filled with electrons.
We're looking a vacant orbital,
right?
It's true that the unshared pair on
oxygen is lower in energy than it would
normally be, but that doesn't
make it reactive. Right?
A pair for a pair of electrons to be
reactive, they have to be high in energy,
not low. We want some vacant
orbital that'll be low,
unusually low in energy.
Chris,
the d orbital, no, it, you know,
if you get to sulfur or something,
if you get down to the next
row of the periodic table,
then their d orbitals that are
vacant in the valence shell,
but on Oxygen D is,
is way up in the next show.
A sigma stars of could be Sigma Star CEO.
And the other possibility could be seeking
to star Ceo any other possibilities
of Sig Sigma Star Oh, age, right?
That's the kind of thing you're
thinking of because when you have,
when you have an old plus that's
protonated, right? Three bonds,
one of them a proton. What do you
think of happening? Losing the Proton,
right? That, that's that sigma star. Ooh,
okay. So that's going to be our, our,
uh,
our electrify all.
That's where the electrons are going to
go into sigma star Oah and break that
bond. Where are they going to come
from? Where's the High Homo? Leon?
Let's go back to you now.
Now you've got the negative charge here,
but there's something interesting
about this negative charge.
The reason that was a good place to put
a negative charge that Karbach slate was
a good leaving group was that there was
a carbonyl group of c o double bond next
door,
and we can denote that.
So we're going to have an sn two at age,
right?
We're going to attack and notice where
we're going to attack from backside,
right? These attacks are always
backside to break a sigma star. Okay?
Now,
so the trouble with this oh
minus is it's not backside.
It's out in the front.
Can you see how we could
get it into the back?
How can we get this charge back near here?
What Way Carl suggested is to move the
anti and it's not bonded after all. Okay,
but there's a clever way to do it.
Not that you're not covered.
What's this?
Does that suggest anything?
That's why carboxylase is a
good leaving group, right?
Cause its resonance stabilized.
But what does that suggest,
Sebastian?
You don't need to use this at a high end.
You could use this and I am, because
the charge is both places here, right?
So we could draw that,
put the charge over there and a
double bond here in front. Okay.
So now we've got it where it needs to be.
Okay,
now we can do the backside attack,
move the Proton over,
right?
And we have those products,
the carboxylic acid without its oxygen,
that extra oxygen that the
per acid had and oxygen,
they added to the carbon carbon double
bond to give a three member green and oxy
reign as it's called,
or an EFP oxide.
Now the interesting thing
about this is why did you know,
I said Carl had the great idea,
let's just move it to
where it needs to be.
But there's a reason I
didn't want to move things.
The reason is that in fact
all those steps are not steps.
They all happen at the same time,
right?
So in fact, when you start with that
material and bring it up to the carbon,
carbon double bond,
all those things happen at once,
right? It made sense looking at
them one of the time, but in fact,
they could all happen at the same time,
right?
So you have minimal atomic displacement
and you are directly from this to
transfer the oxygen atom
and get that,
okay?
But they don't happen
strictly in parallel.
Just because they're all happening at
the same time doesn't mean that they're
all halfway done at the same time.
Some were a little leading somewhere,
a little trailing, but they're
all happening together with men.
Minimal atomic motion.
How do I know that?
Because of this paper that was
published in Jacs at 1991. Now,
that's 20 years ago, and you can do
much better calculations, I'm sure now.
But this is when it was done and
published and it's, it's believable.
This is what they calculated for the
geometry at the transition state,
and they give and every,
uh, in every case, what the,
what the length of that bond and
what the bond angles are. Okay?
Now notice that that Oh woe is strongly
stretched at the transition state,
so it's really broken a lot, right?
But in the electrons in the anti bonds,
it started to break.
It's 1.87 where it,
where normally it was 1.5 roughly.
Okay.
But notice that the Oah bond,
remember that h is going to transfer
from o one to o three at the transition
state is hardly stretched at all.
It started at about one angst drum and
it's 1.01 here at the transition state.
So it,
it actually is going to do most of its
motion after the transition state and I
put k h k d is about one that is,
there's not a kinetic
isotope effect on this.
Does that surprise you that there's
not a kinetic isotope effect
that deuterium and hydrogen are
transferred at the same rate?
Yeah.
What?
What does it tell you when there's a,
when there's a hydrogen isotope effect,
hydrogen deuterium isotope effect.
What does that you about the
mechanism about the transition state,
but it's an intermediate. No, it
doesn't tell you it's an intermediate,
oh,
pardon me.
Step,
the hydrogen is being transferred
not before, not after,
but at the rate limiting step.
But in this case the bond isn't much
stretched at the transition state.
So there's not an isotope effect
because the most of the transfer of the
hydrogen is happening later.
Okay.
So this shows the motion
successive motions.
Here's the transition state.
Then p one p two are subsequent
stages on the reaction pathway.
And if you look at the motion
of each ass of each atom,
you see the hydrogen does most of its
motion from this auctions or this oxygen
after the transition state.
Right?
So just because all these
things are are coordinated,
you don't have distinct intermediate,
you have only one transition state,
but they don't all have to be 50% of the
way from starting material to product
at exactly the same instance.
Okay?
So you can see how the others are moving
as well. So notice that this, that,
that, that what after the transition
state this, the hydrogens are,
are moving down a little bit.
The carbons are moving up,
the oxygen is moving in
here to make the new bond.
And so on and the hydrogen
moving away and this thing,
this the carboxylated at the
top is rocking away, right?
Breaking the oxygen oxygen bond
here and forming the Oah bond here.
So there's only one transition state.
This is said to be concerted in the
things in the sense that things are
happening at the same time,
not several distinct intermediates,
but it's not synchronous. It's not
all happy. Exactly in parallel.
Okay.
Now the name of this transition state is,
they called it spyrow transition state.
Spyrow means two perpendicular
rings sharing a common atom.
So here it's Oh one here's one,
this five member green here
and a three membered ring here,
but they're perpendicular to one another.
You see if they share it out,
and that's what spyrow means to
have a two rings that are Aspiro,
they share an out them and are
perpendicular to one another,
but in fact a very similar mechanism.
In fact,
arguably the same mechanism was
proposed by Professor Bartlett,
your grandfather in 1950 but he didn't.
This was before people thought so much
about spiral and about the arrangement in
space of orbitals as they do now.
In fact,
they didn't think about orbitals at all,
really in 1950 so he had in a pen,
in a paper in 1950 he drew this structure,
right,
which shows the per Roxy,
carboxylic acid twisted around so the
hydrogen can make it from here to here
and, and the oxygen then
be transferred to that.
So this picture is taken from that
publication in 1950 but you'll notice that
the arrows were not at
all carefully drawn.
And what it's not clear what they mean.
This hydrogen in fact started attached
to this oxygen and is now moved over to
this oxygen and the product. So I have
no idea really what that Arrow meant.
Okay. So, but that was old days, right?
Before people talked about
orbitals and so on 60 years ago,
the problem is how about now? How
carefully do people draw such things now?
Well,
we could look at a modern textbooks
that has a drawing of this particular
reaction and draws it in that way.
And what I'd like you to think of as a
for a problem is compare the arrows in
this textbook illustration with the ones
that we developed in the previous frame
to show where homos and Lumos we're
interacting and how electron pairs were
shifting.
And see if you can draw your own diagram
that's more accurate than this textbook
one is. Okay? Okay.
Now, stereo specificity
of this APP, oxidation,
if the oxygen is really being
transferred this way all at once,
the two new bonds have to be on the
same face of the double bond, right?
So if you started with trans to
beauty and use this medical roper,
benzoic acid, then this is
a specific example, Don,
in this solvent Dioxane at
zero degrees for 10 hours.
Notice that this,
that,
that these two methyl groups are on
opposite sides of the three membered ring
just as they were on opposite
sides of the Pi Bod here. Okay?
And this happens with
50 to 52 to 60% yield,
but more significant is that it's greater
than 99.5% trans that now a lot of
this,
this is an actual 52 to 60% yield.
That's what they actually got of pure
stuff and put it in the bottle. Right?
And you know that if you have to
distill stuff at the end and so on,
you don't always get 100% so most
of this loss in this case, uh,
if all they had said was that a 60% yield,
you'd worry what's that other
40% could it be the CIS isomer?
Right? But in fact, that's not what it was
because they tested and found that was,
there was no assist.
There was 99 more than 99 and a half.
The limits of their detection was trans.
So it's a concerted sit in addition,
both new, both do bonds from the
same face of the, of the, uh,
alkene.
And you'd worry about this also,
that this is the more stabilized them
or where the methyls aren't running into
one another.
Maybe it wasn't specific,
but you just got the one
that was most stable.
So of course what they did
is do the CIS one as well.
And that's also a greater than 99
and a half percent CIS now not trans.
So it's clear that that the
reaction is stereo specific. Okay.
Now they did that in order to prepare
those epoxides for a dip for a another
purpose.
It had been prepared before in 1936 by
an alternative mechanism and this was
reacted it, it was two steps to do
it, so it was a harder way to make it.
But they started with the reagent,
h o c l hypochlorous acid.
How do you think h o c l will react?
Any ideas?
What are the reagent that
we've talked about reacting?
Does that remind you of this is a quarry
with an electro negative bond to it
bond to oxygen. What's
the, what's the, uh,
Lumo of that do you think?
Right. Oh, see all sigma star the
same as cc Clc, all sigma star.
And what kind of thing happens
with CLC? All Sigma Star. Remember?
Yeah.
If you reacted with an Alkane,
all right?
It forms a hallowed IA,
Mayan like that, right?
If the only difference is that in that
case it was, see all minus that's leaving,
in this case, it's o h
minus, that's leaving, okay?
But that's drawn in brackets because it's,
it's just an intermediate,
it's not something that you isolate.
It's very reactive.
And what does it remember
you made hydroxide.
So what's going to be the
next stage of the reaction?
How will this react with hydroxide?
How did the one that had a
chlorine on it react with chlorine?
All right. It's an sn two kinds
of reaction, right? And in fact,
you have water here that can also do it.
So it goes a 55% yield after distillation
of this stuff where you notice what
happened was the oxygen attacked
back side open this ring, right?
So this caloric,
this methyl group is back and this methyl
group is back since we started with
sis.
Okay?
So we've got correlated configurations
that these two carbons notice,
it would've been just as easy for
the oxygen to attack this carbon.
It attack this one. It could have
attacked this one, right? So it could,
it came this way.
It could have come this way.
What's the relationship between the two
products you would get if you did those
two reactions?
Hello there.
Even too much.
So you get not just this compound,
but also it's an anti tumor,
right?
But you don't get ones where this methyl
would be in fraud and the hydrogen and
back as shown there. Right? There are four
dietary verse. You only get two of them.
You get the two enantiomers.
Okay, then that,
so that's the first reaction they did it.
They got a 55% yield after distillation
and then very reacted it with Koh.
Notice it's 20 molar Koh.
Pretty strong solution at 90 degrees.
That's a vigorous conditions in water
for two hours. How do you think,
Ooh, minus will it will react with this
stuff. I want several possibilities.
Okay.
What could ooh minus
attack in this molecule,
Chris deprotonated,
nitrogen,
deep protonate the hydrogen. What would
have been another possibility? Chlorine.
It could have been. It could have attacked
none an sn two here on the other one,
but it's rather a little bit hindered.
Right?
And generally proton
transfers are pretty fast.
So you were right the first time the
Koh takes off that and generates that an
ion. Now again, I've drawn
that in brackets because
it's just an intermediate.
What does it do?
Okay,
what does this, oh minus do Chris,
you just told me.
Yeah.
What can it attack?
It is the lone pair on the oxygen. What?
That's the high homo. What's the low Lumo?
See all the carbon
sigma star Carbon Sigma,
Star Card
chlorine.
What would you call that kind of reaction?
Ever see a reaction like
that before where? Oh,
minus the tax carbon and chloride leaves.
Noel,
you ever seen a reaction like that?
And here it says send to,
right.
And it's helped out because this is held
very close to where it needs to be to
do the reaction.
Okay,
so we do that and now
we formed the EFP oxide,
right?
Notice the Stereo Chemistry of,
this is interesting that the two,
the two carbons are on the same side of
the ring the same way they were on the
same side of the Pi bond
here, right? But it happened.
The Stereo chemistry happened in
sort of an interesting way, right?
This is a 90% yield that they
got to this in the second step,
but since they'd had to do two
reactions from the starting material,
the overall yield was only 45% from
the original starting material,
right?
Do you remember what it was when they
used metal chloro per Roxy benzoic acid in
the previous example,
to make this,
to make this same substance
from the same starting material?
You remember what the yield was
not, yeah, it was 60% right?
So nearly half again as much.
At least a third again as much.
And in just one reaction you had didn't
have to do this distillation and so on,
so it was much more convenient that one,
the oxygen just went straight on.
Right? And it was a sin edition. This
one happens in an interesting way, right?
Because first it's a sin edition of
the cl plus both from the same side,
but then there's this sn two kinds of
reaction and it's an inversion at this
carbon. And then here there's
an inversion of that carbon.
Right? So overall, it's
still a sin edition,
but by two inversions.
Okay. So That's interesting.
Okay.
And this is,
this is somewhat reminiscent of
what we talked about last semester,
which is the Sharpless
asymmetric epoxidation it. Well,
I'll just run through this quickly.
We've done it several times before.
So you lose the Aro minus than a
proxy group comes up to the titanium,
right?
We get that intermediate and
react it with Allie allow alcohol.
The OAH of the Al Alcohol replaces
that. Oh, are or that the,
the Aro replaces there to get this,
and now this double bond is
being held near this oxygen.
So the Lumo is the sigma star up there.
The same thing we've been talking about,
and the homo is pie.
And so we've made a bond,
right?
In fact,
this probably this pair of electrons
probably then makes a bond between oxygen
in this titanium rather than the aro
going away. But at the same time,
there's also the p on the
oxygen attacking Pi Star of CC.
This is exactly the
same thing we saw with,
we just saw a few slides ago
with the per benzoic acid. Okay?
So we make two bonds and put the
oxygen on from the same face.
But this particular arrangement makes the,
our configuration at this
tetrahedral carbon, right?
If we wanted to get the other
one, we'd have to rotate this, uh,
rotate this bond to be in front and this
to be in back so that we could attack
the other face. Rotate
it back like that. Okay.
But you'll notice that if you do that,
those two groups in front are big
and they would run into one another.
So you don't do that.
You do the other one and they gives us
specific enantiomers of the epoxide.
But the relevance at this stage
that we talked about last semester,
the relevance at this stage is that it's
essentially the same mechanism that's
involved in the peroxide benzoic acid of
the electrons forming the two new bonds.
Okay,
so that that was a chiral oxidizing agent.
Now this is a big time making EFP
oxides from alkyds is really a big time
operation as is shown here.
This is done with silver ketalysis at 15
atmospheres of pressure and 250 degrees
Celsius and you notice that the source
of oxygen is o two in this case,
that's a really cheap source of oxygen.
In fact,
they do use o two there are other people
who use who do the same kind of thing
who use air,
but it turns out to be worthwhile to use
o two rather than air because you get a
higher yield.
So what you get is an oxygen
that's transferred like that,
that's called ethylene oxide and that
process is generates 20 million tons a
year at worth $20 billion
of making ethylene oxide.
Just to give you an idea,
here's an aerial view of new haven.
And down here is where most of
you live on the old campus, right?
So if you had a bucket that would hold
that much ethylene oxide is a liquid,
it's a gas.
But if you condensed it to a be a liquid,
that's how big the bucket would be.
It would be a,
I think it's 15 times as high as harkness
tower and covering the entire old
campus, right? So that's
a lot of material.
Now that reaction gives 84% yield,
right?
The rest,
the rest oxidizes.
The rest of the original athlete
oxidizes to see co two and h two O.
Suppose you could adjust the
conditions to make the yield higher.
Suppose instead of 84% you can increase
it by 5% if you could raise the yield by
5% that would be worth more
than a billion dollars a year.
So here's a way for you
to make your fortune,
although I will caution you that people
have worked on this a lot to try to get
every last percentage out of it,
right?
Okay.
But in fact,
why we 20 million tons of ethylene oxide
only 0.05% of it is used as ethylene
oxide. It's a, it's a,
it's a disinfectant that's
used in some applications.
It's a gas and you can put it in to
kill microbes or something. But very,
very little of it is used
for what do they use it for?
Two thirds of it is used
to make that compound.
Just add water.
And the reaction that we were just kind
of thing we were just talking about to
make that compound. Does anybody
know what that compound is called?
You could call it dihydroxy ethane,
but it has a more common name.
It's called ethylene glycol.
So it's antifreeze.
So a lot of it is used for antifreeze,
but it's also used for solvent also.
It's incorporated in polymers.
The, the uh, the uh, uh,
polyethylene,
terra Thali that the stuff that makes
a soft drink bottles for example,
has its used in making that
glycols an interesting word.
The delay is from the Greek root.
That means sweet.
Like glucose is the same root.
It's because ethylene glycol tastes sweet,
although we don't taste it
because it's poisonous. So, so,
but the original people did. So that's
why it's called glycol. Great. Okay.
Now that reaction to, to, to change, uh,
ethylene oxide into ethylene glycol
occurs either with basic analysis or acid
ketalysis. So since the focus
of this lecture has been,
uh,
whoops,
this lecture is over.
Sorry, I got carried away.
We'll talk about the mechanisms next time.
Thanks.